so the Cato Institute which blows me
away on face value pat that the Cato
Institute shared this it's a more of a
libertarian leaning outfit but they
reported on a general Government
Accountability Office report that states
that traditional right-wing extremists
make up a vast majority of domestic
terrorist incidents now they're citing
data between September 12 2001 and today
between since September 12 2001 there
have been 85 violent extremist incidents
that result in death 62 of the 85 which
represents 73 percent were committed by
quote unquote traditional right-wing
violent extremist groups 27 percent 23
of the events 27% of the total were
committed by quote/unquote radical
Islamic violence so this is this goes
against what most people fear right the
general fear pad in the society is that
you're gonna get attacked by some type
of Islamic terrorism and this is the the
entire push that we have in the in the
government is like 100 percent behind
you know getting rid of radical
right-wing terrorism but I mean getting
rid of Islamic terrorism but the real
threat in the United States since
September 11th has been right-wing
terrorism right in the top reason in the
world for terrorism at this point is
radical Islamic terrorism but in the
United States's experience since that
since 9/11 it's been right-wing
terrorism I think environmental
terrorism even ranks higher than Islamic
terrorism and and to be sure right so
I'm sure the one of the first things
people are gonna comment and say well
why didn't he include September 11th why
does this this this research not include
September 11th well you know based on
the method methodology that they use
they're not they're not counting the
number of people that were killed
they're counting the number of events so
technically they could throw in
September 11 and still get about the
same results so you would go from 85
violent events and go to 86 violent
events and then you will still have 62
of the 86 from radical right-wing
traditional terrorists and then 24 would
be so it doesn't really change the
analysis when you talk about violence
and terroristic violence here in the
United
States we have more of a reason to be
fearful of billy-bob if I could be
stereotypical then we do akhmad yeah and
I mean the right wing talking point at
least as a as far as Donald Trump is
concerned is that we have to eliminate
Muslim immigration into the United
States cause of the threat of terrorism
but given this study and we've actually
known this for quite some time people
like me should be profiled right it
should be young white males because in
instances of terrorism that's the group
that tends to do it the most in this
country should should I leave I feel
threatened now oh yeah yes I don't mean
to make my distance between us this is I
have enough room to run I have a
different I'm sorry to make light of a
very serious topic but here's the next
part of this right there's a reason that
we are afraid of Achmed and not bill and
that's because our media according to
the same study they examined less
LexisNexis and they pull together
reports between 2011 and 2015
reports on terrorism there was four
hundred and forty nine percent more
coverage of radical Islamic terrorism
than there was traditional right-wing
terrorism in the United States four
hundred and forty nine percent compared
to the reality that since 2011 2001
rather seventy three percent of the
violent experiences that led to death in
the United States has been at the hand
of right-wing so our media their coke
they're complicit in this and in this
perception that we should be afraid in
the United States to be clear that we
should be fair afraid of radical Islamic
terrorism when the reality the real
threat is traditional right-wing
terrorism and of course racism plays a
big part into that too because you know
typically when we think of Muslims we
think of people from the Middle East so
there's this outsider perspective of
trying to fear the other that the media
likes to play up and then there's also
the tactics that the terrorists use so
maybe radical Islamic terrorists would
be more inclined to use bombs rather
than guns and yet we have a gun culture
in the societies yeah we're not as
fearful of that right that's a great
distinction right if you know we we
really won't even consider in many cases
what what one of these people would do
as terrorism we won't qualify it as
terrorism and that's
probably plays a huge role in it as well
we also have a president who will not
say who will say everything about
radical Islamic terrorism and say
absolutely nothing about right-wing
terrorism that has had an uptick since
he was elected so that plays into the
equation as well but there's one last
thing and I don't want to get your last
word on it
one last thing that plays into this is
the fact that you know if you think
about it if you look at the commercials
that are run on CNN MSNBC and Fox News
the commercials that are run are coming
from defense contractors Northrop gun
Grundmann Lockheed Martin you know they
run in and if you think about it
there is no money whatsoever for the
defense contractors in waging a war
against right-wing terrorism in the
United States there is plenty of money
in waging war against Islamic terrorism
abroad so if you think about it they're
the best that interest into keeping the
conversation being about four hundred
and forty nine percent more coverage on
radical Islamic terrorism because
there's actually money in the beer that
Americans have of right of radical
Islamic terrorism
yeah and that conflict is patently clear
because I don't know about you but I'm
not out there buying aircraft carriers
exactly names and ammunition on all this
stuff exactly directly to appeal to the
media outlets exact 100% so it has
absolutely nothing to do with the
audience that's watching because it's
not a single person who's watching MSNBC
who's gonna buy something from Lockheed
Martin but you know you said it best so
but this is the problem and and and and
there's so many layers of responsibility
to this but the fact of the matter is in
the United States since September 11
2001 there have been more incidents of
traditional right-wing terrorism than
there has been radical Islamic terrorism
yet there has been four hundred and
forty nine percent more coverage of
right of Islamic terrorism than
traditional right-wing terrorism